so your hospitals in the 1960s the
original purpose of hospitals was to
nurse people back to health during their
weakest moments but you recently started
to see things from a new perspective you
realize that people are willing to pay a
lot of money for their health when a
person or their mother brother daughter
grandson's life is on the line they're
willing to pay a lot of cold hard cash
now there is a business opportunity so
you shift your focus from the public
well-being to making money you had a few
different ways of generating revenue
like getting a big check from a
philanthropist full-on rapist i'm sorry
did you say you're a full-on rapist no
no no no no i help i help people you
know what i mean i'm i'm a fool a
full-in philanthropist yeah that's
exactly what it is or attracting foreign
patients to fly in for your cutting-edge
health services also known as medical
tourism but that's just not doing it for
you it's not enough and if there's one
thing we can learn from standard oil or
big tobacco is that monopolizing an
industry is a great way to start
charging whatever you want for your
services now you may be wondering isn't
it kind of bad to have the goal of
inflating the price of medical services
for people
yeah so in the 1990s you started a
marathon of mergers and acquisitions
murders and executions mostly mergers
and acquisitions and today the hospital
sector accounts for a whopping six
percent of america's gdp or over one
trillion dollars and all of that money
all that power over the well-being of
the masses was monopolized by 2017
around 2 3 of the hospitals in the us
have been taken over by a single chain
and just like the monopolies of the past
hospital ceos and executives are earning
higher salaries than ever before while
american citizens are paying higher than
ever prices for flat out bad healthcare
if you've ever wondered how you could
create a monopoly for yourself why not
study the one that's left right under
our noses
[Music]
just give me one good reason why i
should have blue cross hospital medical
protection you're sick
when you need it you're better off with
blue cross
the first step that took us hospitals
from a public good to a profitable
corporation was health insurance it was
pitched as a great way to make sure you
could afford your medical bills if you
got sick and it started with blue cross
blue shield in the 1930s
one million dollars that's what the new
low-cost major protection plan from
non-profit blue cross of southern
california could be worth to you now if
you already have blue cross protection
where you work you never have to worry
about being wiped out forced into debt
by hospital and doctor bills my husband
and i have had blue cross and blue
shield for 33 years and with a family of
eight it's been a lifesaver after that
employers started handing out health
insurance too it was clear that there
was a demand in the market and the
healthcare industry noticed but what
started as a way to protect people from
the cost of getting hospitalized ended
up being the exact reason why hospitals
are so hungry for profits today
exactly like how college tuition
skyrocketed after student loans started
getting more popular when you're taken
out of the buying process when all
you're worried about is the cost of
insurance or the deductible you have to
pay you don't care how much an iv cost
you don't care how much a broken arm
costs my insurance will take care of it
when all you're worried about is how
much your monthly payment is going to be
to pay off your student loan you're not
as invested in how much a single class
or textbook costs so colleges and
hospitals can get away with raising
prices because you're not going to
notice and just a few decades later in
1955 the percentage of americans who had
health insurance grew from 10 percent to
more than 60 percent
so more insurance companies kept popping
up hoping to cash in on this lucrative
markets by 1965 president johnson
established medicare and medicaid
government funded health insurance to
make it more affordable
the harry s truman library at
independence missouri is a scene of an
historic event president and mrs johnson
and vice president humphrey arrive for
ceremonies that will make the medicare
bill a part of social security coverage
but the for-profit insurance market
didn't slow down if anything is sped up
and by now hospitals wanted a piece of
the pie too enter for-profit hospitals
and it didn't take long for these new
types of money-making hospitals to start
taking over the industry one of the
first of these for-profit hospital
chains was hca which bought their first
hospital in 1968. the company actually
borrowed the idea from holiday inn the
chain that took over the travel industry
we
got the idea to do this thing
from seeing what holiday ends
uh 10 years before i had done in
changing
basically the travel industry here's how
it would work for-profit hospitals would
go into small towns that had one large
hospital serving the community and they
will set up shop there the thought
process was that this would generate
competition by giving people choices
which meant lower prices and improved
care it sounded like a dream come true
right the for-profit hospitals told
everyone they had better management
better fundraising abilities and better
services than their non-profit
competitors that's how they attracted
patients after all who wouldn't want
that and it was probably true when they
had actual competition by the mid-80s
one out of every seven hospitals in
america was for profits and now it was
time to rake in the dough
just like how a lot of people put off
getting medical checkouts before it's
too late many people put out building
their credits until it's too late and
they want to buy a house or lease a car
or something see traditionally to build
your credit you will need a credit card
but to get a credit card you need
credits do you see the chicken and egg
problem we have here but that's where
extra comes in extra is the very first
debit card that allows you to build up
your credits yes you heard that right a
debit card that helps you build your
credits it is a game changer and here's
how it works all you have to do is
connect your extra card to your existing
bank accounts and based on your balance
extra will give you a spending limit
with no credit check you'll get your
extra card in the mail and then you use
it for whatever you want to buy just
like your normal debit card extra then
covers your purchase and then auto pays
themselves back the next business day at
the end of the month extra reports all
your purchases to the credit bureaus as
credit worthy purchases building up your
credits and just like real credit cards
you'll also be earning reward points
every time you swipe your extra card
plus extra doesn't require a deposit and
doesn't have any interest or fees like a
secured credit card so you're really
missing out if you're not using extra
right now and you can apply for free by
going to extra.app slash jtam with the
link below that's extra.app slash jtam
with the link below thanks to extra for
sponsoring this video
[Music]
there are lots of ways hospitals make
money like receiving donations or
specializing in lucrative treatments for
things like cancer or cardiac problems
but what you may not know is that most
of the revenue comes from people's
private and public health insurance
between the two hospitals want patients
with private insurance more because it
pays the most as opposed to medicaid
patients which pays the least take the
mayo clinic for example which made over
6 billion from private health insurance
in 2018 and only around 300 million for
medicaid in the same year this shows
something very important in this example
a customer with private insurance is
worth 18 times more than a customer with
public insurance so if you're running a
hospital you can now divide your
customer base into two categories
profitable patients and non-profitable
patients you want to maximize the ones
that make you the most money and you
want to minimize the ones that make you
the least amount of money and one big
way to maximize the amount of profitable
patients is the location of your
business hospitals and wealthier cities
make more money than those serving poor
patients by and large one of the
greatest predictors of how much money a
hospital makes is how wealthy the
community is in which they're located
hospitals in wealthy communities often
raise a lot of money in philanthropy and
have well-insured patients hospitals
that are predominantly taking care of
government insured patients or poor
patients tend to struggle but all of
these tactics weren't enough they wanted
more so they moved on to the most
effective way for hospitals to make more
money straight up raising prices and the
tried and true way of raising prices
playing the game of monopoly
so in the 1990s individual hospitals
started merging together under one giant
powerful group this trend of lumping
medical facilities together into chains
continued into the 2000s first wave
actually started in the mid 1990s then
it took a pause and then we saw mergers
and acquisitions come back with great
velocity between 2008 and 2014 over 750
hospital mergers and acquisitions had
taken place in the us that's 125 mergers
and acquisitions per year there were so
many merges throughout this time that in
2018 there were 11.5 fewer community
hospitals than there was in 1975. that
means there are fewer hospitals today
even though there's way more people to
take care of and it's still happening
today in the past two years alone
hospitals have bought 8 000 medical
practices plus doctors have been leaving
their private practices in droves to
become employees for big hospital chains
that basically means small businesses
are shutting down to work for large
corporations while some hospitals are
making more money than ever before the
number of hospitals overall is dwindling
and the ones that are shutting down are
the ones that serve the poorest people
[Music]
if a company had a monopoly on something
like orange juice it wouldn't be that
big of a deal the company could try to
price a car enough orange juice at a
hundred dollars and then subsequently
everyone would stop buying it people can
live without orange juice however
monopolizing hospitals that control the
price of life-saving medical procedures
is a much more powerful monopoly and the
numbers show the cost of hospital
services has increased by over 200 over
the past two decades to put that into
perspective if you paid a hundred
dollars to stitch up a small cut in the
year 2000 you would now have to pay 300
for the exact same thing and it has
buried the masses in a lot of debts
today unpaid medical bills are the
biggest thing collection agencies go
after but with all this extra money it
should at least translate into better
care for patients rights nope yale
economist zack cooper found that death
rates are literally higher in markets
where hospitals face less competition
because these hospitals have no skin in
the game people who work in hospitals
are acquired by the large chain called
prospect medical holdings experienced
this firsthand a surgical assistant from
the waterbury hospital recalled the new
management telling them to wash patients
with paper towels and only change the
bed sheets every three days
makes me feel like i have to touch him i
don't want to touch him at all so why
don't we just put them in the trash
please don't put me in the trash
as hospitals merge other healthcare
facilities and smaller practices across
the us seem to be only left with two
choices the first option is to sell out
and become a part of the monopolized
hospital system the second alternative
is to close their doors for good just
like the effect walmart had on small
shops and while patients spend their
life savings on medical procedures
receive worse care and have their local
hospitals shut down what is happening to
the higher ups at these hospital chains
they are profiting big time
ceo's wages at major non-profit medical
centers rose by 93
almost doubled from 2005 to 2015. in
comparison the typical healthcare
workers salary increased by only 8
percent during that same period so what
is the lesson from all of this it's that
you shouldn't let greed get in the way
of medical
i'm kidding the real lesson is if you
want to make more money selling the
exact same thing subsidize it with
either loans and government money in the
case of universities or insurance in the
case of hospitals that way you take the
buyer out of the buying process so your
rising profit margins slip right under
their noses
sure the hospital monopoly is great and
all but if you want to learn more about
monopolies then you should look into
monsanto where hospitals monopolize our
medical care monsanto figured out a
genius way to monopolize the very food
we eat through some genius tactics and
it just so happens that we have a
future-length 40-minute documentary on
monsanto available right now as a
private documentary only to members of
this channel all you have to do is click
the join button below sign up and you'll
get instant access to this knowledge
that they will never teach you in
business school like seriously you're
not going to find a monopoly 101 class
at harvard even though it's a business
degree that costs a hundred and eleven
thousand five hundred dollars this on
the other hand costs five dollars a
month and there's even a refund policy
if you join and don't think it's worth
it for whatever reason you can email me
and i will personally give you a refund
there's new private documentaries
dropping every month and they're not
going to be available anywhere else
click the join button below to watch now
[Music]
you